Mashallah. Next question of quite equal
importance actually is about how people
welcome Ramadan with certain sayings.
Ramadan Mubarak. Some people say it's a
bida and others say it's a sunnah. What
is your uh ruling on this
>> to welcome month is good. Alhamdulillah.
And our prophet always informed the
other people about this month. And as I
mentioned earlier that our beloved
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam it's
mentioned in Musl number two page number
had number 7148 which is also repeated
it is mentioned in sunai chapter number
five had number 21106 that our beloved
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam he
used to always tell the people when the
month used to approach when it used to
come. The prophet will tell the people
in advance, "Oh people,
the blessed month of Ramadan is
approaching you
and Allah subhanana wa ta'ala has
ordained for you that you fast in this
month." So the prophet used to welcome
this month. He used to wish other
people. The same way today if you wish
as the prophet said the blessed month is
approaching. If someone says Ramdan
Mubarak, this Ramdan Mubarak is more
often said in the Indian subcontinent by
the Indians, by the Pakistanis because
this word bubarak though barka is an
Arabic word. Barka means blessing and it
is nothing but blessed month. But when
the Indians and Pakistanis when they use
the word bubara, it is more of a sort of
congratulation.
When someone passes examination they say
which derive from the Arabic word. So
when Ramadan comes they wish Ramadan
saying that it is the blessed month or a
sort of congratulating
and wishing each other that the blessed
month is approaching. So according to me
it's not a bada. You can welcome the
month. It's a good thing that you're
calling this month a blessed month and
you're informing other people reminding
them that in this month is a lot of
blessing. So according to me it's not a
bada but how you wish the words you
choose that is muba that's optional like
in Indian subcontinent we use the word
Ramadan mubarak in the Gulf countries
they use Ramdan Kharim so all these
words are good the holy month or the
blessed month or the month of
forgiveness so the choice of words is
yours but the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam he used to say to the people
that oh people the blessed month of
Ramadan is approaching so I feel people
should wish each other And they should
remind each other about this blessed
month.